all right let's go now to charles
stratford he's in mario poll in
southeastern ukraine and charles is in a
car for us charlie just tell us where
you are and what you're doing and what's
happening there
hi darren yeah well you join us now in a
car we've come to do
have a look around
the city i am i'm going to turn the
camera around now so you can see it i
mean there are still people on the
streets it is obviously
increasingly quiet um and in the last 10
minutes or so there have been another
series of loud blasters we cannot
confirm where
um
but as you see you know there are there
are pedestrians
moving around there is light traffic
we're on our way to one of the city's
exits
um to try and get a steer on
how many people are trying to leave the
city
as we've been reporting mariopol of
great strategic importance
one would think to any kind of invasion
by russian forces
largely because of its huge
port
its naval base and potentially as a as a
hub to be able to connect
areas of the east the eastern front in
donbass with what analysts say could be
a plan by putin to connect that with the
section north of crimea to create what
analysts describe as a corridor as you
can see there's people here
waiting by bus stops very very little
traffic
the shelling here started in the early
morning it has been very sporadic
and we are getting reports from
a naval base interestingly
around 100 kilometers west
of
um
west of marriott a town called baradansk
the military there saying that
there were positions in that area that
were being shelled they said
um
they believed from russian forces in
russian annexed crimea
um so yeah i mean as you can see
very very quiet streets um
yeah i'm passing interestingly this is a
bank
so you can see people obviously
desperate to try and um increasingly
desperate to try and get money
um get money out and we have been
expecting some sort of some sort of
cyber attack if you like the network's
obviously still going strong as we
wouldn't be able to bring you these
pictures but it's quite a surreal
experience here as you as you can see on
the streets there are still you know
people walking walking around we've also
heard reports we've been speaking to
people in some of the villages that
we've been visiting in the last
week or so on the ukrainian government
controlled side villages on the front
line
people in those villages saying that
they are hunkered down in their cellars
the shelling has been very heavy
overnight and it was ongoing this
morning and those villages i suppose are
around 50 kilometers from here
we've also had reports as i say which we
cannot confirm
of
a village that we
visited north of kharkiv
um about two weeks ago directly on the
border with russia now this was an area
that had seen absolutely no fighting
whatsoever
in the eight years of the conflict
and certainly according to our sources
uh one source now describing that
village as being having been flattened
um so reports there of heavy shelling
potentially fighting um north of kharkiv
but as i say we are unable to to confirm
that
charlie just just just talk us through
you were you were mentioning earlier
charlie about going down sorry charlie
let me interrupt you there you were
talking earlier about the strategic
importance i mean i think it's worth
just reminding our viewers about the
strategic importance of mario paul you
were saying uh it acts possibly as a
potential hub for some kind of corridor
uh across from donbass uh down to crimea
just just just talk us through how that
would work charlie
well the theory is is that if there was
a push by russian forces and and
separatists russian-backed separatists
from the donbass region
in the east
that push could well be joined by a
symbol a simultaneous push by troops by
russian forces in
crimea they would push up towards towns
like kerason
big cities that we visited in the last
few weeks they would push up north from
that and they would head east
the forces coming out of donbass would
head west and there is a very strategic
road there which i believe is the m14 if
i'm not not
my memory deserves me well the m14 a
very strategic road there to take that
area of of land to control that
and join up russian forces in crimea
with obviously the pro-russia
separatists in the separatist held areas
now the reason why analysts have been
saying this is a potentially important
move
um
and they've been saying this for months
now is because in 2014
the uh
the ukrainians once after after the
russians have taken annexed crimea the
ukrainians took control of the water
resources north of crimea
there are canals there that run off the
dunepa river that supplied up to 85
percent of the peninsula the crimean
peninsula's water now we know that
the russians russia has been building
wells in the subsequent years or trying
to build wells on the crimean peninsula
we know that very quickly
they built a bridge across the kirch
strait to connect
the uh the crimean peninsula with the
russian mainland but the theory is is
that they are still suffering
um
very very difficult conditions with
water so
that
certainly
according to military analysts would be
a viable and not inconceivable option
for russian forces yeah to to create
that corridor from the east the donbass
region um
the separatist control area of the
donbass region to those areas of
northern crimea
charlie um it is extraordinary watching
you driving around in mario pole whilst
this invasion is happening um let me get
a final thought from you charles i mean
there are not many people walking around
on the street
and that's uh
that that could give an indication of
just that
the atmosphere that people are scared is
there an atmosphere of fear of
trepidation uh you know do people think
this is the calm before the storm
well i think what's interesting as well
as you can see the streets here are
considerably busier than the streets we
we saw when we initially came live what
five minutes or so ago there's a lot
more traffic here and the traffic is
moving in both directions and we're
heading in the direction of going out of
town
um certainly the shelling that we heard
earlier we understood was um
was along the coast
um and that's where we were close to
where we we started um started reporting
started talking to you a few minutes ago
um
one thing that we hear those throughout
our travels in this area over the last
few weeks is
it's surprisingly
surprising how how how
seemingly little afraid many people are
in in this uh in this area they've kind
of resigned to the fact that this
conflict has gone on for for eight years
um
and
it's also important to recognize that a
lot of people in this area are very
sympathetic to russia as well
they have a a cultural identity a
language that they use that
is russian so they're they a lot of them
do identify with russia
but the overlying feeling certainly in a
town like mario as you can see this
morning you know this is you can see
traffic moving around there's a there's
a couple there
very relaxed walking around um there's
this feeling that um well surely this
couldn't happen there couldn't be a
battle to take control of this huge city
on the on the as of sea
um
so yeah by and large people are have
have been very sort of controlled in
their in their descriptions of the of
certainly of their emotions there is no
underlying sense of panic that we are
seeing at the moment i mean this is a
this is quite a popular shopping area
um it doesn't look like these people are
rushing to get out of the city does it
so yeah
it's going to be interesting we'll know
more the the closer we get to the outer
the outskirts of of the city but uh
yeah this is where we are at at the
moment i think as i mentioned earlier
it's also important to recognize that
mariopol has a lot of fighters in it a
lot of military and a lot of
paramilitaries in it groups that uh
there's another queue there i think for
a bank yes you can see people queuing up
there
at an atm
yeah the city's got a lot of weapons in
it a lot of our men a lot of men that
are prepared to fight
and
some of these paramilitary groups have
been very successful in defending the
city in in 2014 for example so
if there was to be some sort of push
into the city i think it would be not
inconceivable that things could
deteriorate very rapidly indeed and you
could well be seeing
yes
potentially a lot of civilian casualties